wir haben nach 22 einhalb jahren an der
regierung erfolgreichen jahren an der
regierung hier eine sehr herbe
niederlage eingefahren
und damit haben sich die schlechten
umfragewerte leider bestätigt wir hätten
uns gewünscht dass das besser wird wir
alle haben dafür gekämpft
und ich sehe hier nicht nur auf der
bühne sondern auch im saal ganz viele
freundinnen und freunde die mir
unglaublich viel kraft gegeben haben in
den letzten monaten und die alles aber
auch wirklich alles unter ganz
schwierigen bedingungen dafür getan
haben dass wir es doch noch tränen
ortsvorsitzende aus allen verbänden ich
sehe gemeindeverbandsvorsitzende ich
sehe kreisvorsitzende sehr einfache
mitglieder ich sehe junge frauen und
männer die sich für die cdu entschieden
haben weil sie wahlkampf machen wollten
ich sehe j&j
ich sehe die mitglieder des tobias hans
team liebe berliner
die
katz wenn man in der 10 tage isolation
sind kurz vor der wahl zu einem nach
hause kommen das vorbeibringen es tut
gut
und ich sehe wie meine frau meine
familie die vieles aushalten muss nicht
nur in diesem wahlkampf sondern auch
über die letzten vier jahre
sehe
unsere seniorinnen und senioren ich sehe
die cdu die vor den werkstoren gekämpft
hat und ich sehe die miete ich sehe die
nsu ich sehe den evangelischen
arbeitskreis der alle die hier in
unserer partei verantwortung tragen und
liebe freundinnen und freunde ist nicht
selbstverständlich dass ihr da seid denn
ich weiß wenn man solche zahlen
sie dann mal weg will eigentlich am
liebsten das weite suchen den kopf in
den sand stecken ich ins bett legen aber
das liebe freundinnen und freunde ist
nicht unsere cdu sah cdu saar kämpft und
sie kämpft auch dann wenn man verloren
hat und deswegen liebe freundin freunde
ist für mich klar ich übernehme die
verantwortung für dieses wahlergebnis
denn das wahlergebnis mit einer person
verbunden als spitzenkandidat und
deswegen werde ich auch persönliche
konsequenzen mit dem vorstand mit der
fraktion am morgigen tag beraten
und ich bin sicher wir werden gemeinsam
so wie wir als cdu sah immer gekämpft
haben auch in diesen schweren stunden
dieser zäsur der machtverlust nach 22
einhalb jahren gemeinsam gute lösungen
finden damit wir im sinne unserer partei
und auch im sinne dieses sagen dass das
eine starke cdu braucht egal in welcher
rolle auch wieder nach vorne blicken
können dazu werde ich meinen beitrag
leisten mit der übernahme dieser
verantwortung das ist mir eine ehre und
liebe freundinnen und freunde es war mir
eine ehre diesem land gedient zu haben
als ministerpräsident und eine ehre euch
als parteivorsitzender gedient zu haben
ich bedanke mich für all eure
unterstützung fehlen muss
[Applaus]